- On this episode, I
talk about wine, Reddit,
and becoming a Youtube sensation.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Everybody, this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk and this
is the #AskGaryVee show, Episode 11.
Steve, can you give me one. (laughs)
11.
Hey, guys, super excited for Episode 11.
Fun fact number 11, 11 was worn by the
sleeper last pick that
you should take in your
fantasy draft this year.
Jeremy Kerley.
He's going to have a big year.
- [Voiceover] Chip asks, if
you owned a winery in Napa,
what your left jabs look like?
- Chip, thanks for the question.
And honestly, I've been
reading the feedback.
Thanks for the critiques yesterday.
Some of your took it a little to far.
I mean, what I was really
saying from critique
this show was, give me compliments,
not actually nitpick and
find something to upset me.
But anyway, you know, I want
to start answering these
questions in a different
little bit of a way,
and so thank you guys.
You guys continue to evolve this show.
Big shout-out to the people
that have been tweeting
and Instragramming the fact that it's been
interesting to watch the
show evolve from one to ten.
It is pretty crazy for the
amount of shows I've done
and videos I've done to
watch it actually have
an evolution even with intention.
You grew with that, Steve.
Show Steve.
- [Gary] Zak, do you agree with that?
- Yes.
- So to answer your
question, I'm gonna answer
it in a way that I hope
everybody who's listening
doesn't miss the point that
this works for everybody,
not just wineries.
If I was a winery in California,
I would actually make
my jabs Wine Library TV.
Let me explain.
Could you imagine if a
winery in Napa Valley
did a show where they
tasted wines from all over
the world that were not
from Napa and critique
them and gave their thoughts.
All of a sudden you start looking at them
as an authority instead
of somebody who's just
pitching their wine, right?
Everybody wants to go the route of like,
let's show the day in
the life, and they take
video, like cropping the
crap and like tasting.
Nobody cares about that.
They will care a little bit
about the dog running around.
And if you teach them
the dog's name is Goldie
and make more videos about Goldie, they'll
care about that.
But what they really want
and what you really want
is utility.
The reason this show
exists is this is the next
coming of my ability to give utility.
I'm giving content that actually
is a little more tangible.
Now it's opinions, so take
it for what it's worth
but you've decided you're
gonna allocate your time
and I've somehow become
important enough to you,
or you're curious enough
about my POV and brings value.
Value comes in entertainment,
value comes in a lot of forms,
but I really do think
opinion, context, information,
these things are very powerful.
And so to answer your
question is, I would just
review other wines from
the world and give my two
cents on that, because
then, you're leveling up
and not just pitching.
In the same way that everybody
here, instead of talking
about their products or
their ebook, or their blog,
can talk about other stuff.
Hence, look at the structure of this show.
These are questions from you
that I have to respond to,
thus they matter more to you.
You have to put out things
that matter more to others.
That's a little bit of my curve ball.
Take it for what it's worth.
- [Voiceover] Ivan asks, do
you respond to posts, tweets,
emails, messages, or get your staff to?
Some people delegate this.
Do you?
- Ivan, one of the single--
By the way, I selfishly, this
is a humble brag question.
Put a humble brag hashtag.
(tinkling)
Ivan, the thing that I might have
the most pride in in the world is that I
have responded, that every tweet
that has ever come out,
has come out from these two
fingers.
Every email, these two fingers.
Now the content, Mister Stunwin here helps
me quite a bit to make it actual English.
But it cut--
Look, Steve, I mean you're here.
- [Steve] Yup.
- And I know you're not
a sell-out so let's go.
I mean, like, you--
- The tweets, the emails--
- [Gary] No, not that.
- Those were your own words.
That I already said, we know.
I do get very nervous
that it has to be like
my transcribed--
- [Steve] Oh yeah.
- We have like a lot of--
Thanks, Zak.
Thanks for heading out.
Like we have a calibration of
like, early on you're trying
to help me in my limited
adjectives and like--
(laughing)
But like, I do put like,
that's an important part.
- Yeah, absolutely it all the--
All the basic material
is this guy, 100 percent.
I just add the sprinkles.
It's not even sprinkles.
It's just like, rearrange the plating.
- He turns it to English, guys.
I can't write for (beeps).
And so, at the end of the day,
it is something that
matters so much to me.
So I do it, all me.
No assistant, no social media
person, no Vayner employee
that's really good at capturing
my voice that was my fan
for nine years, none of that.
- [Voiceover] Chef asks, what
food or foods have you added
to your new lifestyle that
you're enjoying the most?
- Chef, once again, I went
with a different tactic.
There is no foods that are new.
No, we went a different route.
Mike, who's on the last episode,
we went to the supermarket.
I told him the things I
liked that were conceivably
healthy.
Mangoes, you know, shellfish.
Luckily for me, I like
everything and so there has
been no additions.
This has been about subtractions.
- [Voiceover] Arsh asks,
how can I converge my vision
of being a Youtuber with
parents' vision of getting
a university degree?
- There's a very simple answer.
Most people say, what college
did you graduate from?
Not what was your GPA.
So you should easily be
able to become a solid
D student or C or whatever
it's needed to graduate,
which should give you the
flexibility to become a massive
Youtube sensation.
- [Voiceover] Chelsea asks,
what are your thoughts about
Facebook banning like-gating soon?
- Chelsea, I actually think this--
Look, I think Facebook out of, gets--
I think Facebook is maybe one of the worst
PR'd companies in the world.
They've done so much more
good than people realize.
They are the gold standard
of the future of marketing
because they do so many
things for their users
because their users are
their business and they
understand it.
By not allowing brands
to like-gate, where like,
call like hard-core like
actions, they're actually
helping brands and businesses
and small businesses
understand that it's
not about getting people
to like be rewarded with
a free crown if you like,
if you subscribe to this show.
(tinkling)
Here, you understand what
I'm doing here right here.
Right, DRock? All right,
you know, win a free crown,
if you subscribe to this show.
That's not gonna do me any
good if you really care
about gold crowns.
And the amount of people
that built their fan bases
on Youtube, excuse me, on
Facebook, in 2009 and ten,
by offering free iPads was insanity.
Because those were Apple
fans, they weren't fans
of your cereal.
So I think Facebook, once
again, is making a hardcore
move that is actually helping
the users and the businesses.
- [Voiceover] Greg asks, your
thoughts on Reddit, not social
media or do you find it useful?
- Greg, Reddit, probably sits
for me in one of the three
or four places on the
internet that I underachieve
on and wish I did more with
historically and spent more
time with.
I don't spend as much time
in the Reddit community
as I should.
Steve's a huge, huge, huge fan,
huge, huge fan of Reddit,
and as Steve became
a bigger part of my life,
and somebody I cared about,
it actually quietly made
me check it out more.
We did an AMA with my book.
We're trying to do one
right now for social media.
- [Steve] Our social media.
- Yup, our social media, so
we're gonna try to do that
in September.
I got an email in my inbox.
I know you've been asking this, my fault.
Do I find it useful?
The question is, are you asking me as Gary
the human being, do I find it useful?
The answer is, not that
much because I'm not taking
advantage of that amazing world
that's been created there.
Do I find it useful as a marketing tool,
I have looked at it that way,
and feel like it's a very
interesting place because
that community is very solid,
you don't want to jump in and spam.
Reddit's done a nice job
creating some advertising
structure that I think is
consumable to the community
and good for the brands,
it's up to the brands
and their creative shops
to make it Reddit-y.
And I think a lot of
people struggle with that.
But if you understand the
slang, the lingo, the vibe
of the that community, and
you can play on that space.
I find it useful as a place
that business can be done.
But business 2020, which
is really respecting
the community, or you are
going to get annihilated.
Thank you, my friends
for watching Episode 11
of the #AskGaryVee show.
My question of the day is very simple.
What are you doing this weekend?
Thanks so much guys for the first couple
of weeks of this show.
As many of you know,
because this is a very
hardcore group, haven't
really started the big
promotion yet of this show, I'm going away
for two weeks coming up.
I'm a little bit scared
that you guys are gonna
fall off while I'm gone,
but it's the last two weeks
of August, and you should be spending time
with your family and chilling
out because that's what
happens in America, inspired by Europe.
And I kind of expect the
DRock to probably make
a mix tape for the first
11 shows or me basically
telling him to do that.
And I will be back with vengeance.
You keep asking questions,
I will keep trying
to answer them.
(upbeat instrumental music)
(beeps)
Hey everybody this is
Gary Vay-ner-chuk and you're watching
the king of--
(beeps)
Today, I'll talk about, little
old ladies, luck, and being
a great right hooker.